criada en el condado rural de tyrone en
una familia de destacados republicanos
irlandeses la carrera política de
michelle o'neal comenzó como concejal en
2005 con él fue elegida para la asamblea
de irlanda del norte en 2007 donde
sirvió como ministra de agricultura en
2011 y ministra de salud en 2015 en
enero de 2017 cuando el vice primer
ministro martín mcguinness renunció
o'neal se convirtió en la líder del sinn
fein en irlanda del norte fue un momento
con una importante carga simbólica a sus
40 años se convirtió en la primera líder
del partido que no había formado parte
del irá aunque su padre brendan doris
cumplió sentencias por delitos en el irá
antes de convertirse en concejal del
sinn fein y celoni lideró a su partido
en las negociaciones para restablecer el
poder compartido en irlanda del norte en
2020 luego que la renuncia de martin
mcguinness llevará a tres años de
estancamiento político en el país
sanz bueno el sinn fein está
decepcionado pero no sorprendido de que
no se haya llegado a un acuerdo todavía
en enero de 2020 o'neal fue elegida como
viceprimera ministra de irlanda norte
una posición que mantuvo hasta la caída
del ejecutivo en febrero de 2022 tras la
renuncia del primer ministro del partido
unionista democrático a unir se la
asocia comúnmente con el ala socialista
de izquierdas del sinn fein en su
campaña se centró en temas como el
aumento del costo de la vida y la
sanidad
queremos invertir mil millones de libras
extra para reparar nuestro sistema
sanitario
haciendo menos enfoque que sus
predecesores en la reunificación